a new study reveals that 75% of  Millennials are actively saving for  retirement yeah and this think about it  this goes against public perception and  the cliche that Millennials are bad with  money they're actually saving much more  than we thought and we know this for a  fact because of scenes like this one  captured earlier today at a local bank  take a look  hello how can I help you I'd like to  make a deposit into my retirement  account investing in your future  wise choice avocado juice you've really  been saving up there we go good news  you're vested it's funny because I'll  never be able to afford a house I'm Mike  Bloomberg and I approve this  you